c'est une fête du canada dont se
souviendra longtemps cette famille
originaire de l'inde sa première en tant
que citoyen canadien
mais pour les habitués des célébrations
ici c'est le calme qui marquera le 1er
juillet 2020 dans une capitale
habituellement festive présentement ses
marges
depuis que 13 14 ans ici chaque et
chaque année c'est plus de 13 des voix
qu'il ya pas que je perçois pas de
musique pas de grandes scènes ou
d'artistes pour amuser la foule on avait
invité les citoyens à célébrer dans
leurs quartiers et c'est loin de la
colline du parlement que le premier
ministre justin trudeau souligner sa
fierté d'être canadiens
on a eu ni nos forces pour traverser des
moments difficiles
impossible d'ignorer le contexte de la
pandémie
mais justin trudeau se veut quand même
optimiste on a vu dans les pires moments
à quel point les gens sont remplies de
compassion en un pays résilient à cause
de la de cette entraide des gens et
c'est ce qui a toujours fait la
différence
la gouverneure générale du canada s'est
adressé aux canadiens dans une vidéo
nous profitons de la fête du canada pour
célébrer qui nous sommes cette année
c'est un peu différent
les leaders autochtones se sont eux
aussi tenu à l'écart des grandes
célébrations
nous avons des défis nous devons
continuer à travailler pour réduire
l'écart entre le chef national de
l'assemblée des premières nations
on va faire un tour virtuel du canada
nous avons besoin de sortir de chez vous
comme ils l'ont fait depuis le début de
la pandémie
les artistes ont offert un spectacle
dans l'union
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des numéros variés des artistes de
toutes origines pour célébrer la culture
d'un océan à l'autre virtuel jusqu'au
bout et célébrations se termineront par
les feux d'artifice en réalité augmentée
que les canadiens pourront voir sur
leurs téléphones intelligents ici julien
lapointe radio canada ottawa